From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We were able to see so, I don't know.
So what I'm going to do is a quick real marker for the...
No problem.
...and then what I like to do, I usually start to go fairly chronologically.
I always start with people's family histories and infectious words that came from me.
So, you've got some.
So we'll start there and...
Yeah, face to grandmother and grandfather who didn't play.
Oh and I should...
I'll also just tell you right now that because we were recording digitally,
we stop every once in a while to just save the files.
No problem.
We'll take a little break.
Yeah.
And anytime that you want to take a break, just let us know.
Yeah, I've done.
Yeah, okay.
And anywhere you want to take the interview, you take it.
You ever get to Ben Rouge, the new museum, state museums that's there, you hear me.
Okay.
And we did a lot of digital recording then.
So yeah, I've been on both sides though.
I've done a bunch of radio and stuff like that.
I like it on the side.
Yeah.
All right, great.
I prefer that side, but yeah.
So today it is the tenth of May and we are at the African American Museum in Fair Park in Dallas, Texas.
This is David Klein talking.
David Klein from UNC Southern Oral History Project and Virginia Tech.
And I'm here with Charles Chuck Siler.
Also with John Bishop who is behind the camera, John Bishop of Media Generation and UCLA.
And we're all here today as part of the Civil Rights History Project on behalf of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's Museum of African American History and Culture.
And Chuck, I just wanted to say thank you so much for your part of this project.
You're welcome.
I'm happy to be here.
And if we could start, if you could just tell us a little bit about the family into which you were born.
And how you may have seen that environment shaping the kind of work and things that you went on to do.
Well, I think what is, I don't have to, I had a big family for one.
My mother and father were divorced early though my father and I did get to be good friends later in life.
My mother was a beautician.
And so naturally she was in a position to hear everybody's business.
And I think she was well trusted because she didn't tell her what she heard.
My grandmother was a piano player.
Her career was spent playing for churches, teaching music, choirs, this and that.
And I was her oldest grand, her first grandchild.
So I could have been a little bit spoiled.
My grandfather, I was the first grandchild that he had, that he had a chance to spend any time with.
And he was alive till I was seven.
So he was an influence in terms of the fact that he abetted my creativity.
I guess my grandmother found me when I was, as she said, about 50, 60 months old.
I found a pencil.
And we had these lower half of the walls in the house that they had bought were wooden.
And she saw me trying to draw on the wall.
And her story was that I wasn't just scratching on the wall but I was trying to draw little stick figures and things.
So she gave me, told me if I wanted to do that, ask for paper and pencil.
And so two of the first words that I learned according to her were paper and pencil because she said I started asking her for that almost every day.
But the upside for her was she could put me in a corner with a pen, a big cheap Indian pad, which I remember.
And a pencil and leave me there all day.
So the upside was she used to always start out reading every day with the cartoons.
So the attitude was she'd get a laugh and first they'd get to the serious news.
And I come from a family of folk who had, I think, great senses of humor.
My father, in fact, also, when I got to know him as an adult, I discovered that his sense of humor was very well intact to him.
And my mother is 92 and she still can be funny when she was too.
But my mother had six brothers, all of whom had a lot of influence on me.
And one of my father's, his oldest brother, Eugene, was another influence.
He lived about 40, 50 miles away and laughed for yet, but we were in contact.
My family in Baton Rouge was one that encouraged me.
All of them were readers. So I grew up reading.
I started reading when I was, and my younger brother, when we were both about two.
You know, we were able to read a sentence and do things.
When I started school, I was five.
And they let me, you know, my first grade teacher was a neighbor.
And she took me because I was the only black kid in the neighborhood at the time.
And so I went to school with her.
And I did well enough that she asked the principal who also lived in the neighborhood.
But things were different then because my parents, my mother, had gone to school or had been taught by half of the same folk who taught me years later.
Everyone knew everyone else.
You know, I had relatives who, yeah, I had folk who, one of my aunts was secretary at my high school.
Another one taught, taught, taught home economics.
It was married to my mother's brother.
And so, you know, there were, those people there, my uncle Ralph was head custodian at my high school and became later parish white.
Supervisive custodial things in Baton Rouge.
So the family was very well known in terms of that.
He was also a caterer, great cook, you know.
And I learned a lot from that.
My wife tells me she married me because I could read and cook.
And I have to blame my family for that.
But at times too, when I did things that were sort of, as they like to say now out the box, I was supported by that.
You guys made me start thinking about this because I was trying to go back to when I first protested something.
And my first protest, as much as I laugh about it, now was against Boy Scouts.
Because in the 50s, when I was probably 11, 12 years old, we marched in the Boy Scouts parade.
And we were proud of the fact that we had little drill teams and we could very moves and this and that.
But in Baton Rouge, they put the black boy Scouts behind the horses.
And I think I did it the first two years and I had to clean my shoes after that.
I decided I wasn't going to do that.
I had a scout master who wasn't in line with that with me.
So I quit the Boy Scouts and started an explorer post at my school.
But it was the first active protest that I did and got away with.
I went to McKinley High School in Baton Rouge.
McKinley was well known for being greater academics, greater athletics, and we would fight anybody and usually win.
And South Baton Rouge was, you know, in the city of Irwin, it wasn't as bad as some of the inner cities.
Now we didn't shoot as many people.
Folk weren't getting a shot, this and that.
But you would fight and you had to learn to do that kind of thing.
When the Southern University demonstration in March of 1960 happened, they had to lock us on campus.
Because we were ready to go out and do it.
We started a little bit more about that when you said you were ready to go out.
In what way and what had you been?
We were ready to go and join the demonstration.
You know, we heard about it.
Somebody said students from Southern are marching downtown.
And most of us were ready to say, let's go and join them.
You said you had a sense of what was going on for the Korean and the world community.
We knew because we had, you know, I've told kids this and I hate to say,
but I think the kids that I used to talk to about the Civil Rights Movement when I worked at the State Museum,
you may have that in Louisiana, but there were a few schools that I went to where they were interested in things like the Civil Rights Movement.
And there were social studies teachers who had the sides up, the white and black, you know, white and colored at that side.
And I told them about things that we used to do to protest.
You know, we would take a paper cup, go into the men's room, use it, and pour it over the white water fountain.
It was our way of protesting what we could, you know, because we couldn't, you know, and we were treated bad.
You know, folk would throw money at you.
My uncle Jean started the first black cleaners in Lafayette, Louisiana.
He had to, when he, in the early days, sit in his shop at night with his gun.
Because they threw bricks, they shot, they said, but he had a reputation for shooting back.
And he was, he was a person that, until he died, I love the man.
Like, he was, you know, he felt that since my father and mother had divorced and they gone,
he felt obligated to be close to me, keep me linked to the silo side of the family well.
The silo's had left Alabama, my uncles and my father and that much because they had a reputation for shooting back.
And, and mobile, in that area where they were from, in the 30s and 40s, that wasn't a part of it.
My father also played baseball, which let him see a lot of it.
He had some good friend, Satchel Paige was one of them that I happened to meet once and I thought that was one of the great moments of my life in 1967.
But my father stayed involved with baseball most of his life.
He started the Compton County Mac baseball league.
And he had, he told me the stories about the fights that they had in California.
But that league sent over 600 players to the pros.
And when I worked at Southern for a few years later, I started with one of the coaches at Southern League Flint Royate,
played ball with my father, put a black pelicans in New Orleans.
And when he found out that he played third base, second base and my father was a shortstop.
And he said, you're a child or son, dad, I tell you.
And I put them in touch and a lot of guys out of Compton went through Southern and to the other HBCUs.
So you know, little things like that, that family network of sorts.
Most of my uncles, with possibly one exception, worked for themselves.
My uncle Peter, who was one of those that I was named after. His name was Ernest, by hits the E.
In my name, my uncle TJ was an insurance salesman.
Most of them had been in World War II. All of them, my uncle Earl was a tailor.
They had learned these things. My two younger uncles had been in Korea.
Well, one was in Korea, one was in service as a medic during the Korean War, but he couldn't get a job when he got out.
So he worked as a waiter, and like I said, he was the one who later became supervisor in the Baden's Urge School District of custodial services and things.
And he had his own business until, long after he retired. The thing was they tended to be independent.
My grandfather spoiled me. Like I said, I was the first grandchild that he had in two families to have time with.
And so, you know, we would listen to all the old radio shows when he had to babysit me because my grandmother had choir rehearsals and things during the week. This was her living.
And she made, for that time, a fairly good living, playing music.
Our first thing, and John would appreciate this, that she told me was a story about what got her in the gospel.
One part was she was raised by her uncle and aunt, who, her uncle was a Methodist minister named Mansfield Jones.
But she got punished because she was playing blues. She liked to play the blues.
She played a stride piano. There's a piano player out there now who I've heard play with her, and I wish I had recorded it.
And Henry Butler, who has a style very similar, big left hand, big clapping left hand.
And she played the yellow dog blues for me. I have loved the blues ever since.
Okay, for all she did with gospel, the blues got me, okay.
And a lot of my friends that I grew up with had batted, and we were just blues players and things like that.
And so we, you know, are still, I'm still tied to that.
The act of civil disobedience, my senior year in high school after the Southern demonstration, a group of us,
I'm trying to remember names, Moses Edwards, Betty Jones, E. Nola Price, the oldest Washington who's not with us any longer,
were among, we were a part of the end, some of us were in double ACPU Council, folks.
Betty Jones. Betty G. Jones, yeah.
And I think Moses is still alive. We graduated in class of 60, but after we took our final examinations about two weeks before we were supposed to march,
we decided that we were going to pull our protests. And so my family looked up one night and there was with a picket sign in front of the state library,
because we had tried to use it. And they didn't let us in.
So we, there was a, was there black, there was a black, so called black branch somewhere.
There were black, black, black, we had to call the branch library. And I spent a lot of time there because they finally, at one point, moved around the corner from my house.
I would, you know, they had to read 12 books and you get the certificate thing. Then I'd read 40 books in the summertime so I could have three or four centimeters, you know.
But Miss Bennett, who was the librarian, had a son, Herbert Bennett, who was one of my first teachers, who was a very talented artist.
As I said at that time, I had an uncle, Willie Jr., we called him son, who was also a very talented artist. But at that time there was very little outlet there.
And my uncle's son had to leave Baton Rouge because he had gotten into a fight with some guys.
The best description I can give you of him is he was, he looked like Burt Lancaster in brown face. He was about six feet tall.
And he had a Charles Atlas build, but he had been driving trucks and loading trucks since he was 10, 11 years old for the Belonin brothers at Baton Rouge.
And so he had this bill that was there. He died after being shot by another American soldier.
Well, he didn't die immediately. He lived nine more years, but he was shot with a machine gun.
And he had probably almost 60 surgeries over the years, removing shrapnel as it came to the surface.
But during that time, he was very much an influence on me also because he was encouraging when it came to my art.
And he showed me that he could draw.
And I had never seen anybody do it that well, nobody black.
I'd seen all of these other things. And later when I had a chance to study with some, I think, great artist.
I was able to appreciate it because some of them had come there.
My uncles and my grandmother, particularly when we hit the state library, I'm going back to that, didn't put me out of the house.
You know, they.
Can I stop you just for a second?
Yeah.
One is you mentioned sort of you are on the customer graduation.
So there was a thing issue going on.
So if you could say a little bit about that. And then also specifically what it was that why you targeted the library.
We couldn't use it.
And I was like I said, I at Harvard branch, I tried these.
I don't know if I read every book in the library, but I read most of what I could find out.
Okay. And one, I went through one phase where I lived.
The part of Baton Rouge where I grew up in one point in this history, it's called Markets and Old.
We had snakes all over the place. Every kind of snake, you know, I mean my backyard was a veritable.
We.
To overcome fear.
I went and read everything I could all snakes.
And one point I wanted to be a herpetologist, I drew snakes, sketch snakes.
And I had teachers again like Ben Hall who was my biology teacher.
Mr. Hall let me bring a pet snake in for demonstration.
It was a hognose snake.
Let me doctor a country.
His name was Irving. He became a cartoon later too.
But Irving was the first opportunity that I had to do this.
I had teachers who always taught us, saying when I was in school was that you had to be twice as good if you were black to get half as much.
My teacher said, okay, you got to be three, four, five times as good.
And we grew up with that.
We had silent support from a lot of them even though they couldn't speak up when we went out and protested.
Now the reason we did it for the most part after we we had been planning it.
But the reason we waited until after we finished our examinations was because of the fact that they couldn't use missing that against us.
Okay, and we had about two weeks.
We finished examinations and about this time in May, I graduated once the 26th, which I'll never forget because it was my aunt's birthday and later my wedding day.
We were married on the 26th of May.
But during that time we started our protest.
We started picoting, we started doing things.
And they had to watch us.
And there were other kids at Southern High, a few from Capitol, who were Capitol Avenue, another one of the schools, who were getting involved in the activity because greenville had happened.
Then Southern happened.
People don't know this, but Southern's first demonstration was the largest of the mass demonstrations to hit the South in 1960.
Marvin Robinson + Marvin Robinson + Donald Moss + Major Johns + Major Johns, who lives here in Dallas now, he's recovering from a stroke I was told.
Marvin Robinson + Donald Moss + Major Johns, who I think is back in Louisiana, I'm not certain.
But I've got a friend in Baton Rouge, Mayo, Bruce, who was from Marvin Robinson + Donald Moss + Major Johns.
In Marvin Robinson + Donald Moss + Major Johns, they tried to integrate the library there and he had a good put to his here about a sheriff.
And when he tells that story about it, I've never seen him talk about it without becoming emotional.
But if you've ever been shot at him or if you've ever had someone threaten you that way, you don't forget that.
And it was something that made me, it made it difficult for me to be nonviolent later.
I met Martin Luther King in 1962.
I had a chance to shake his hand and he at the NA convention in Atlanta walked around, came around the room and shook every by all the young folks, shook our hands.
And gave us a word or two of encouragement, but I'll have to backtrack to get to that point.
But they wanted to put us out of school in 60, but they couldn't.
One reason being all of the guys that I named that were a part of this that I can remember now were the best students in the class.
Our valedictorian and salutatorian didn't participate, but then again, different reasons.
Most of us were the ones who had gone through it, who lived out there with it, who put up with it, and we weren't as sheltered.
And we were very forward and we were going to be out there saying what we had to say.
So we did what we could, we started that.
Things settled down a bit and all of us went wherever to school. I went to Southern.
You talked a little bit about this already, but the support behind you, I mentioned this again.
So clearly you've got some of you have your families.
You talked about, I mean, your family so many because of this history of independent business owners and this kind of independence that your family actually had.
But you often see in competitions.
One of the things that was funny, my uncle Ralph, when my grandmother died and I was talking after the funeral and he told me, he says, you know your grandfather used to write my grandfather wrote a bicycle to work.
He had worked on the railroad and as he got two old to work trains, he became the janitor at the roundhouse in Baton Rouge.
I remember going with him when I was about three, four years old.
He suddenly took me down to Cedar and he's giant trains.
You know, when you, that tall in the train is 20 feet, it looks huge and everybody knew Willie, you know, as he was.
And he always wrote a bicycle to work.
And my uncle Ralph told me, he says, you know, daddy wrote a bike and that's what we all called him daddy.
He says to work because he wasn't going to pay a dime and have somebody to tell him where to sit on the bus.
Okay, he generally wrote, or cover alls to work.
But every Sunday morning he was had Deacon at his church, he was in a suit and he would walk to church, you know, so I've gone with him a few times here there.
But he was, you know, he was, he was a model for manhood and I was his oldest grandchild.
And at that time he was going to, you know, give it.
I didn't know that then but whatever was there was a part of what later made me understand that I could speak up.
And I had learned from my mother and from my grandmother that right or wrong, if I felt I was right, I was going to say it.
Now sometimes I got spanked for it, but my mother learned early on that I was hard-headed enough that if I knew I was right and she learned that she could speak me and I told her the last time I got a spanking I said, well, you can do this, but I'm not going to cry.
And so I took the spanking and I looked back at it and my question was, are you finished?
I never got another one, but I had to sacrifice that because then I had my mother and my grandmother in each year in stereo talking to me about what I had done wrong, what I did.
So I was kept on track.
In school, I had some teachers.
Mr. Hall was one in particular.
I ran into his grandson a few weeks ago here that I hadn't known.
Mr. Altamus, who had been in World War II also with my uncles and things, who had what we now call post-traumatic stress disorder.
I didn't understand, you know, guys would laugh because they said they could set off a firecrack at Mr. Altamus with diamonds or the death columns.
Well, when I got back from Vietnam, I apologized to Mr. Altamus for having been one of those guys who would laugh when somebody did something like that and say, oh, Mr. Altamus, well, I understood why he drove onto the desk.
I had been through rocket attacks and things like that.
Okay, so those loud noises, I still got to know us from being too close to a howitzer, you know, without protection.
And those kind of things, you know, you learn to appreciate later in life.
But these were the guys who also were supporting us quietly.
They didn't want to lose their jobs. We didn't want them to lose their jobs.
But they didn't say, I never heard you wrong.
You know, Mr. Hall has two, some daughters who are still alive who are like little sisters of mine.
Because Mr. Hall would sit there and tell you what they, you know, and we heard the stories of what people had gone through and they were reinforced.
And in the neighborhood, all of that, Dr. Dr. Dupuy H. Anderson, whose father was a member of the end of, was on the board of the NA in Baton Rouge,
we were on a panel together at LSU in February of this year.
And Dr. Dr. Dupuy H. Anderson, who was a dentist, was one of the leaders of the Civil Rights Movement in Baton Rouge.
In 1961, I started off, I was a foot soldier, I wasn't one of the leaders.
I got involved because they needed somebody to make science.
I was an art major. And Diana Manning, who died a few years ago, and I were two of the first art majors to make science.
Yeah, protest science. We were at Southern. I was a sophomore. The funny thing is, I was a person, I was a member of the person rifle,
and I was a real team, and I was at the time of Pledgey, and I later became a PR, but five team leaders next to me was Hubert Gerold "H. Rap" Brown.
Hubert Gerold "H. Rap" Brown, who later became known as Hubert Gerold "H. Rap" Brown. I've known him since junior high school.
We got to be close in college because we used to hitchhike to school together. We lived in the same part of town.
For protection in part two, because it wasn't easy to be out there, and it was always easier to hitchhike with somebody.
We would do that from Southern because we didn't have bus service to the school.
If you were up there late at night, we had to get home, so it was either walk.
There was a part of Baton Rouge called Dixie that we didn't really want to walk through at night.
Because anything could happen on scenic highway. We tried to catch people coming off campus going on, and everybody got to know us over a period of time.
In 1961, we started doing this, and then they started teaching us nonviolent protests, you know, how to go into the famous curl in the whole thing if you were getting beaten.
We had sessions at the college and off campus. We got to let us use his place, and after he closed it moved the tables aside.
We had Dave Dennis Sr from Corps Jerome Smith, who was still a new audience. He runs in a organization called Tambourine & Fan.
We were all fault Jerome Smith. Jerome was a freedom writer.
He has stories that, like I said, he was a leader. Ronnie Moore is still a new audience.
Rani's daughter, Desi, is married to Wess Anderson. Rani, I think, is still running a program or working at Tulane if I'm correct.
We're actually going to talk to Darmi Bailey.
Yeah, I know Darmi.
Can I underline for a second?
Yeah.
I'm saying two things that you... One is... Could you tell us what happened with the man who got to the shooting gun by a white malnose third story about that?
My uncle? My uncle just happened to be a person that would fight back.
The reason he had to leave Baton Rouge was because he got two guys jumped him.
It was during a time when they could get away with things like beating up on Black Folk.
I knew of cases where cops would have Billy Club practice as some folk we used to call it on people.
My uncle, as I said, was one of... He was strong enough to take the front of a Volkswagen. He could literally lift it on a system.
He hit a guy and supposedly broke his neck from what I was doing.
And he had to leave. When he got drafted, he was working in a war plan, a munitions plan, a something of North and Kansas or somewhere like that as close as I can get to it.
And he had changed his name. He added an R instead of Willie Moton Jr. The family name was Moton in Louisiana.
He added an R. He was Willie Morton Jr. That was enough in those days to get out of that.
But he went into the military. I don't know what prompted it.
But he was a person who would fight back.
And generally, he was a person whom if you had a fight with, he was going to...
I didn't want him to ever hit me. He made me go back and fight a guy who was bigger than me once.
And I stayed in the fight more out of fear of him than getting hurt.
And I took a good butt weapon for about half an hour before the other guy gave up.
Because every time I wanted to stop, I looked and he'd be standing there just watching me.
And after it was all over, he told me, he says, I didn't say you had to win the fight. He said it said you had to fight.
And once he says, bullies don't want people to fight back.
Oh, he says they were. I never had another fight with that guy here because he understood that I was going to...
My uncle died not long after that. But one of those pieces of shrapnel knicked something and you know, that killed him.
And he was like 39 years old at the time. But the thing was, you know, it was one of the lessons I learned.
My uncle, Gene, who my wife knew and my son also got to know, after his experience in Lafayette,
moved out of the heart of town into a little area called Scott that at the time was fairly well unincorporated.
But he had about two acres of land, maybe three. And he was never further away than maybe 20 feet from one of his hidden guns.
Because he was always wary of that.
My father was also, you know, all of them. They weren't in R.A.
But the terrorists, they were worried about were a totally different brand.
One of the brothers, Earl, became a minister in Paris, California.
And his son, Don, is a bishop now. I don't know how to do these things. I'm not a good church girl, OK?
But the family has a history like that.
My uncle, Gene used to tell me, he says, I didn't shoot the sheriff, he says, but I almost shot the deputy.
And they were looking for him at one point. And the guy who was the deputy that saw where he was hiding was a friend of his.
And knew he wasn't guilty of anything. And told the guy he wasn't there.
This is the story he told me later. He said, and so he was able to get away and get away from mobile.
And he said, no, he had to leave. And so, you know, I had that growing up.
I had these guys, these voices in my, and all of them were standing up.
My uncle Ralph, the funniest story that I've ever heard.
He was a guy walked up to him when he was on his knees, saying his prayers in the barracks when he was in the army and started playing the dozens with him.
And when my uncle Ralph got up, beat the guy.
I mean, beat him really good, then turned around, got back on his knees and finished saying his prayers.
You know, and I always had these guys saying, you know, so when it came down to that, when I was 19 years old and that activity started,
I was going to be a part of it. And I went from painting protest signs to going through the training.
And then I went on a city in the first time. And that was, you know, different because I joke about it.
Now, I can't help it. I think it's a part of what made me decide that maybe at 80, I'm going to become a full time stand-up comic or something.
Every guy that the terrorists that we had to deal with, I don't know where they got these guys from.
But there were, you guys all 6, 8, 6, 9, they looked like pro football players. They didn't have their hoods on, but you know, we knew who they were.
And they were there to intimidate. Well, at the time, I might have weighed 175, 180 pounds.
I was the same height that I am now, but that's a lot of difference when it comes to looking at 300 pounds.
And there were arms as big as my waistline was at the time. So, I became more of an observer to a point after that because my attitude was going to be that if something happened, I was going to have to fight.
You know, if no more than just to get away, but I, you know, was not good at seeing women get hit or thinking I could take that without, you know, some kind of response to it.
We went to jail, 12th of December, if I recall the day correctly, a group of us were arrested and taken downtown to, for picketing, we were picketing the Bon Marché Center, I think. I don't throw it a street.
And we were taken into the bad room's jail and we were given the usual, if you come back down here, we're putting you in jail, we're going to keep you up to our, you know.
And Willie Bradford, who's in Shreeport now, Willie Bradford, Thomas Pete, Jane, Theta Ambrose, I think was with us.
I'm trying to remember Janelle's last name and it just slipped my mind, but Bradford turned their cop and said, what are you going to do with the other 5,000?
And this guy turned red. I thought he was ready to hit him, but Bradford and the thing I think it made it even worse was Brad was black, but Brad was, if you didn't know, he was black you.
You know, couldn't, but he was, you know, he knew and he wasn't hiding it. And he and Thomas Pete, who are very light skinned guys, I think sometimes enraged the race is more so than the darker folk did.
You know, they knew why we, but these guys didn't necessarily, you know, they could have slipped across the line and passed not.
And Southern always looked like an integrated school because of the different, the broad range of color that you had there.
And so the next day we went back out, we protested again and we were on a bond to jail. I spent the Christmas holidays of 1961 and the East Baden Rouge Paris jail.
Now the day after that, not just Southern University students, but Baden Rouge citizens joined the march and they had from what I was told from the guys who were down there, at least 5,000 people were down there.
The press underplated.
But we were up on the line on top of the jail house and it was split. There was a neutral area and there were cells on one side, cells on the street side.
And we were, we walked over to the street side and we were standing up looking out at the windows and we could see the crowd assemble.
And there were people going in both directions as far as we could see through the oak trees that were down there.
And they were protesting, they were protesting our arrest.
Yeah. We had been arrested once. There was a rally tonight when we got back. We went back out the next day because they dared us to come back and we took the dare.
Okay. Or I don't, if I recall correctly, I didn't stay at home that night because they, so I was afraid somebody might try to talk me out of it.
But we went back downtown. One of the things I was kind of good at was whenever we had protest, I used to get to do, I had to stick with voices.
And when I knew sometime, you know, I didn't tell the guys I was doing this all the time, but I would get on the phone and call down to the police and call in a report that they had some knee-resout there.
And that they were over here, they're all over the place. And they would go this way and we'd be over here.
And, you know, I had that streak. I, you know, I still have it. I couldn't be different. But we went back down. They came and they put 340 of us plus in a space that was built for about 42 people.
When the demonstration came downtown, we were looking out and we saw, you know, everybody's dressed neatly. Nobody's about to start anything.
And they started singing. We should overcome. And we started singing back.
Okay, it was 13 of us then. And now or later they had, they were bringing them in, you know, from this.
But...
It was a 13th in the first day.
Yeah, we were in jail. On one side, the girls were, there was a wall separating us in the girls line, or the female line as, you know, the women's line.
And we started singing back. From a top to jail, yeah, they could hear us. And, you know, you got kind of a cheer or something that went up and they started singing and then all of a sudden we heard pop, pop, pop and dolls.
And the police actually rioted. It wasn't the protesters. They were peaceful. But just the song, we should overcome, set them off.
And they used enough tear gas. And we were on like, what would have been the fourth, fifth floor of the building, I guess.
We could smell the tear gas in the line. They moved us and locked down that half of the jail.
So that we couldn't get into the cells on that side. They later opened it back up because we didn't have anywhere to go. It was almost standing room only.
Okay, we all came out of there a lot older than we went in. We were in there for three weeks.
When we came out, it was January 2nd, I guess. And our lawyers, Lolis Elie + (Bob) Collins + (Nils) Douglas, Lolis Elie, Robert F. Collins and Nils R. Douglas, came to get us out.
Lolis Elie and I are still friends. His son is a journalist who is now living in LA. He worked on the Traumae television series as a story editor.
But Lolas used to write for the pick of union in New Orleans. His father was a little guy. He was about five, four, five, five.
And when they brought us downstairs to release us, he came through a crowd of giant deputies. And it was like Moses parting the waters.
And Lolas was fearless, I guess you say. That's the only thing I can think of that is cry there. He's another person whom, you know, if I had to recommend people to talk to, is in New Orleans, and I said, you got to talk to Lolis Elie.
Okay, because his stories were, had to be great. But we continued the protests when we got out of jail.
Felt in Clark, who was president of the University of Southern.
Did you get bailed out or how to do get bailed out?
We were bailed out, yes. Which illegal picketing, things like that.
The charges were thrown out before we ever got to trial. But they had really, they knew it was most of the reason we were in jail was to quash the protest.
You know, jail was used as a punitive form of punishment. It wasn't about whether we were right or wrong. It was that we shouldn't, we were out of, you know, we were uppity.
Okay. And I've been called that since then. So it's not gone, you know, and I mean recently.
It was like a few long, good luck.
Oh, great.
Okay. So I got to pick up a laptop.
Okay. When we were all finally, you know, banned from campus, again, somehow some of the people who were friendly.
And since I lived in Baden Rouge, I was able to ease off to an awful campus to visit, you know, see my girlfriend at the time.
Things like that. But I started work well and we were expelled as a kid.
Yeah. They there were a variety of different reasons, you know, grades, this and that.
I was bored. I think my grades were probably borderline because of the fact that I've missed so many classes and things like that.
Though I passed, I'm trying to remember if I flunked anything, I may have had flunked one course was up to because of that.
But we were all put out of school, basically. And a lot of people didn't return to school as it was all to bad.
I was, like I said, 19 years old or 62. I made 1962. In fact, I was 18 still.
But Rev. T.J. Jemison, Reverend Robert Walker, who were within double-ACP and Baden Rouge offered me a job working for the NAACP running a voter registration project.
And I walked over, I guess, two-thirds of the Southern part of Baden Rouge, door to door, trying to teach people how to pass what was supposed to be.
And I say, in quotes of voter registration tests, basically it was a form that they had to fill out.
And any and every excuse that could be used, you know, short of giving your birthday down to the second was used to keep people out.
We found some old voter registration forms and tests and things that they used to give that round ahead.
And she's had students nowadays who look at them and can't believe what they had to go through then.
I worked out of an office on South 13th Street. And I always think back about that because it was an area where when I was a kid I had worked as a shoe-shy and boy and clean up guy at a barbershop on 13th and government street in Baden Rouge.
I was born about three blocks away on South 13th. It's now Eddie Robinson Sr. Drive after the coach from Brownlee.
And you know, it's funny because Eddie and my mother and that were all classmates. And they all went to Leland College and stuff like that before.
But we, I worked that area. Fortunately in that area most of the black people knew me.
So I had some who would determine not to get involved. One guy chased me out of his yard with a hole.
Another one had a dog that wouldn't let me out of the yard once I got in. You know, he wanted to play. But whenever I started toward the gate he growled.
So when the man got home he let me out. But I was active with the NAACP there.
Why was that you think that some words to reluctant to get involved with you?
Fear? You know, they didn't want to lose their jobs. I had a few relatives. Usually it wasn't the immediate relatives.
You know, those who may not have liked what I did didn't say anything because they would have to put up with my grandmother.
And my grandmother backed me. I have to give her a credit for that. She knew that sometimes it had to happen.
And that I had been raised to stand up. And so it was consistent with how, with my upbringing I guess, if I had to say anything like that.
And it was me, I guess. You know, I was also still trying to write and do things like that.
And so through the spring and the summer of 1962 I worked out of that office during the protests.
The NA Secretary, Lady N. Pearl George, who was just a few years older than I was at the time, worked in the office with me when, you know, she wasn't going to school herself and doing whatever.
She became a city council person years later. But Reverend Rev. T.J. Jemison, aren't the Rev. T.J. Jemison and Reverend Walker were the two, and Dr. Dr. Dupuy H. Anderson were the two.
The NA Folk, who were closest to me at the time, I, and I guess I'm, I can say this now, I got, I went to the NAACP convention in Atlanta in 1962 representing Baton Rouge.
And I walked in and almost started to fly with a clansman outside the Atlanta convention center. They were picketing the, and, you know, I stopped in the middle of their picket line to make them walk, you know, in 19 years old.
I just turned 19 at the time. And so I was, you know, I was almost 200 pounds and big enough to think that I could be. And the guys had to say, come on, you know, I'm going to eat you wherever I'm off of this.
But a guy named me out Jones and I during the middle of that convention pool of city and had a little place called a crystal in Atlanta.
And we had some kids and Jewish kids who were there, went in, bought food, and had his sitting in front of us. We walked in, they got up and let us sit down and we proceeded to eating well.
They didn't know what to do with us. So they locked the place, put hot water on the stove and pots, turned them up and steamed up the place. Basically, I guess trying to, you know, heat.
Okay, I went to Vietnam because it wasn't cold. Okay, so heat wasn't going to run us out. And Al, I hope he's still alive. From say, look, yeah, you know, it's like I'm from Louisiana, you know, you know, summer or not. You know, you don't steam me out of a place. I think that's going to do it. I've been in much worse than that.
And we got in the sort of hot water with some of the NAACP leadership because we didn't know at the time that we weren't supposed to have done that because they had sort of had a no protest agreement going on.
And nobody told us about that because I was there alone.
Ralph Casimir, Dr. Raphael Casimir, who was with the New Orleans chapter, was there then. We didn't know each other, but I ran for a national office during that time for the Youth Commission.
And they finally got rid of me on the fourth vote. Okay, but Clara Luper, Daisy Bates, oh boy, what's my girl's name? Oh, I'm trying to, Ella Baker.
Those ladies took us aside and told us we were okay. You know, they had their problems with some of the leadership at the time too.
And, you know, I guess it was in one sense, second class citizenship for women that was still being overcome in terms of the old hierarchy.
And, and a leaders group, you know, organizations did this, which was one of the things that put me outside of a lot of it and I think made me go to where I am now.
But Reverend Rev. T.J. Jemison was one of the people that I admired because he was a country preacher.
Reverend Walker, on the other hand, was a well-educated preacher. They were both AME ministers, but they were committed and they kept us on track.
You know, because of them, I met Medgar Evers. I was at a meeting with him and his brother Charles, who I love.
Charles was one of my heroes because Charles Evers, you know, Charles Evers said, you ever hit me all you lose is the swing.
He said, you're going to get the blowback. And, you know, I was philosophically, I was with him on that.
But we had a meeting at the church on South Boulevard in Baton Rouge. And I didn't realize, you know, that little, the impact of that because three days later, Medgar Evers got shot.
And I was, well, I was very upset. But I had gone, I was already back in school. I was writing for the school newspaper, cartooning for it and stuff like that.
And staying sort of in front of the dean of students is desk almost every week for something that I had done.
And he later told me he missed me because he enjoyed I low-confering. He was always wondering what I was going to do next.
Or what we were going to do next as a staff because we had a group of, at that time, energized students.
You know, we had a reason that in 1963, 64 or 65, we had reason to want to, our president.
Yeah. I ended up going back to school, back to Southern. I started, in fact, I went back that fall. I almost, they tried to get me for a violation of a federal injunction in the fall of 1962 because I took some kids to a few-quail elementary school.
And I embarrassed the principal who, you know, who still didn't give a rant about us, a sort of communist outside agitators coming in and doing this and that and I explained to him in front of the TV camera that I grown up down the street from that school.
So I wasn't exactly an outside agitator. I was an inside agitator. And I wasn't going to stop agitating. Well, they wanted to put me in jail for a violation of a federal injunction, 10 years, 10,000 out of fines that I, that I, that I,
Revin Jokes called in AA office and I think it was Gloster Current who was from Dallas.
Was the attorney that came down and talked to the district attorney in Baton Rouge, Sargent Pitcher, whom as funny as it might sound, it handled my mother's divorce and whom as a poor little kid, my grandmother,
or their fed once or twice when he was growing up and he remembered her. But my grandmother was very well known around Baton Rouge, you know, because of her, her church work and her choirs and this and that and the fact that she was, so all of those factors I think had something to do with my not going to jail because it was trumped up anyhow.
And the first thing was they were trying the injunction was against core. I was a car carry and a NAACP member at times. So NA was not enjoying in that sense.
And NAACP also had the, had the litigatory for us. They had, you know, they, they had, they're a good marshal and people like that. And so, you know, the, they, they weren't going to win that fight.
And as I said, when we went to jail earlier in 61 that the charges that they tried to put us to lay on us then were kicked out before we ever got to court.
Because of the, you know, they were basically unconstitutional. It was something that was punitive that they were trying to do to make a shut up. They didn't do that instead. Some of us went in different directions. You know, I used to send nasty cartoons to the, to the Klan rally, Klan rally. I knew it didn't know who I was.
I was never known who I was on the streets, but I picked on the, I picked on the clan. I still pick on, you know, they couldn't, I don't want to say just the conservatives because I think anybody who's doing wrong.
But I'm as a registered independent. I have the right to do that. And I still do.
So we're back with Chuck Siler. We, you'll notice that we did move locations because turns out that the planet actually moves.
So our light has shifted. So so have we, Chuck, if we could pick up, fortunately, due to time, we're going to move a little bit faster than we have been.
Okay. We have been talking about your work with, in protesting with the NAACP. I wonder if we should move on to leaving college and going west and then your work around the North.
I got involved with the theater. So I'm with the American theater being with Frank Silvera. It managed to trade off a production design for some acting classes and a little bit of money and things like that.
I started what was going to later become some time in Hollywood. I did work a little bit with Willis Thomas and the guys at the Hollywood NAACP in the seventies.
But I was drafted in 67 and I wound up going through one of the those funny things careers in the military that probably would make a good sitcom.
Because I was, I had to go to Vietnam to get the job that I wanted. Oh, you know, that I would that I enjoyed doing or and it was basically because I had been through here we go, nuclear weapon school.
Though I had a degree in art and a lot of experience of writing for newspapers and I did manage for three months to be an editor of my college newspaper just so I could legitimately say that I had done that and I had to have some,
all some folk in that administration lobbying on my the health to do the president didn't want that. But it happened in my last summer at the school I did edit the newspaper and that next fall I edited the alumni news letters.
So I graduated from Southern, I finished officially in January of 66 after going back to school.
I my stay in California the first time was fairly short, not quite eight months, nine months. I went back, I came back to the States after the military.
Now in the military again, we ran into I was on charge of quarters the night that Martin Luther King was killed and being one of the I was one of the older guys in the company. I was 24 at the time.
I was a late drafty, you know, I didn't know I was going to have to go and there was turnmoyle we had to talk folk out of I was at Fort Huachuca, Arizona at the time and we had to talk folk out of fights.
I had to talk to some white officers who were afraid to let black soldiers go into things and I had to tell them how not to go into some of the communities in Tucson because the Hispanic and small black community that they had then they were more afraid of what might happen there than what was going to happen in the other communities where they were more likely to have problems and that was the way community.
But the managed to get through that it was not a good time. When I got to Vietnam, I wound up instead of being a truck driver as they had wanted me to do after that strange odyssey from nuclear weapons to light vehicle driver school.
And because I could type and I already had a degree in things like that I was sent to an AG section as a senior clerk and I wound up because someone told them about that editing the AG newspaper after about three weeks of doing that.
What did they do?
I did an AG general. The information office needed a replacement. I come in a clerk who was from California and considered me a homeboy as they used to do told the guys to say we got a guy over who's got experience as a writer.
He had seen a scrapbook that I had with some of my stuff in it and Fred Carl who was in COIC of the office called me over and asked if I might be interested in the job.
They knew I was an artist because I started cartooning in the AG newspaper which was a memograph sheet. I learned the draw. I learned etching from doing a memograph and dinner.
I was like, oh, okay. Naturally I said yes. I had a chance to travel, do stories and things like that. We were attached to the first logistical command which was a command information office.
I got to play with a little radio. We wrote stuff for television. We did a variety of things. I hate to see I enjoyed that part of the military service.
We had some problems because again we ran into racism. It was deeply embedded in the older NCOs.
I met Grindel Howard who later became first female sergeant major of the Army who was a good friend of Fred Carl who was my NCOIC during that time. She came to visit.
There was a major who later became a general Sherian Cadoria who went to Southern. She was a major at the time that I was there and was kind of surprised because she was a senior my freshman year at Southern.
Here is another Southern who showed up in the office. So head friends. General Richards used the fact that I had a top secret clearance from nuclear weapons to be able to do some sessions and things like that.
I didn't want to be clear to do but he could activate my clearance when he needed it and did. I got to see the country. I got to write about the black soldiers who were doing things.
I got to see the whole town news releases which were something that I guys weren't getting a lot of but then again I was the only black guy that I knew of at the time in the field doing stuff.
There's a guy named Arnold Buschwa who was a cameraman in New Orleans, Channel 6. Arnold was on the Mo Pick team and I happened to go out with them when they were getting ready to do a story.
We didn't realize for 30 years that we had met each other at the time until we started talking when they did that. I came back, went to work for Southern. I was hired as sports information director and assistant public context director.
Can I interrupt in this afternoon question which is, I mean you had this position in Vietnam where you were sort of you were a voice for the black soldier or helping to sense and do things.
I had to point to a boy that showed that one point that before I started doing it we had probably 5% of the hometown news releases.
Not the news stories, this guy is a mechanic doing this kind of story.
Now we were all doing stories, those were little pick up things, take a picture of a guy, write a brief little thing, send it down to Long Bình, it would go out to their hometown newspaper.
You know, who were they were from, those kind of things, what we put in so they know where to send it.
Some of the guys that I met were talking about earlier like Charlie Black from St. Louis. These were guys that I just happened to be because I was older.
And you know, they would come through and we'd run into each other and talk.
And I went out to this orphanage and we were talking earlier about this.
There were kids who had lost limbs. We saw a kid who had his job blown away.
I mean, he didn't have the lower half of his face and they had to figure out ways to feed him this and that.
I didn't think he was going to survive.
But the things that you saw every day were, you know, the things that you see in a war, even if you're not a grunt, you know, if you're not an infantryman,
are things that you can't often talk to people about when you get back because they have no way of understanding it.
I had some good friends who were guys who were LAPD. In fact, when I, in the 70s, who had been over there, we could have conversations, we could talk about what we had seen.
And they understood the fact that there were race rides in Vietnam. People don't talk about that.
Okay. There were times when troops were coming in from the fields and trying to tell guys who were stationed in or near cities.
My information office was at Heddon, here, or at his compound in Qui Nhơn.
There were fights downtown between soldiers who were coming in out of the field, black and white soldiers because white soldiers would tell black guys, you can't come in here.
They were waiting to make it hold up. You know, we all green, supposedly. You know, and it doesn't mean light green, go over here, dark green, go over there.
Or that wasn't the way, you know, it was supposed to work.
I tended to be an advocate at times with it necessary when guys were getting in trouble.
I was doing a little troop pushing when I was at Fort Wat Chuka. And I found out that a lot of guys, I had a platoon of guys at one point that I was in charge of.
That had all been for the most probably 70% of them have been in the stockade. Usually for things that had nothing to do with crime.
But I was a Hispanic guy because they didn't understand the language. So in my platoon I started getting the guys who spoke English to work with the guys who didn't.
You know, to help them because they were going to need that kind of thing.
When I came out of the military, I still haven't changed, like I said, basically.
With what I do as a cartoonist now, it's a running commentary on what's going on. And yes, I pick up and point out racism.
You know, and it comes from both sides. Like I said, I'm an independent. I see some things from the Democrats and I see it from the Republicans.
My best friend used to be a media guy for the Libertarian Party. One of my oldest clothes, but we fussed and fight.
We were probably doing until we were 90 if we could live that long. But I was able to going back and I have to go back in 1962 for a minute.
Two of the guys who we came, good friends of mine, Bill Rusky and Larry Wigg at the time.
We're two young white guys who were trying to write a book about the civil rights movement. I don't know whatever happened after a while.
But Lawrence Maxson Wigg was a part of the Maxson family that the truck people in.
They talked me out and going to a Klan rally. They left me actually.
I wanted to go to a Klan rally with them and hide in the trunk of their car at Stone Mountain. That's how silly I was.
But they were an LSU for the summer and did that. What I learned was, you know, I think during that period of time was how to take people according to who they were and how they were to me as opposed to.
Because I made some friends that I couldn't ask somebody just because they were black to risk their life for me.
And some guys did some things that were about the fact that we were friends as opposed to the fact that we had different colors.
I try to look at the heart of the person. I think that's what's important to me in terms of where I am now.
And again, Sam Castan was my buddy in Baton Rouge. You died back in the wet 99, 2000.
But Sam was the one who said, you know, to him, you know, the full race of the men were A, A, B, B, and O.
And again, you can't tell who's what because we laughed. We were both B's and both our wives were old. So we said, well, we're in the racial marriages, even though they looked the same.
But if I'm going to the hospital, he says, I'm not going to ask you for a piece of, I'm not going to say give me some skin. He says, but I will say give me some blood.
And so we started looking at it and then why we were friends because sometimes friends have to question why your friends.
I learned over the years when I worked in Southern, I'm trying to catch up so we can move forward.
Some of the guys that I had a good chance to work with when they were students, Mel Blount, Mel Blount + Harold Carmichael + (likely) Isiah Robinson, if you're a football fan, I see a Robinson who played for the Rams.
I was a few years older than them. I was 26, most of these guys are 21, 22. And I still say refer to them as my kids, okay?
Because I was just older enough to deal with the Bob Love and I who played for the Bulls or classmates.
And we were, you know, well, he was a year behind me, but we were good for you know, the friendships that you develop over these times and doing different things.
When I worked at Glaming, or well, not at Glaming, but for Black Associated Sports Enterprise, this was the first Black Sports Network on television.
It should have been, it should have been what became BET.
But we were trying to do things. I was trying to convince people that we should do films on folk like Robert Smalls.
And they were going, who's Robert Smalls? Well, I had a bad attitude in those days and I called a couple of producers some things that they didn't really like when it came down to being saying you're stupid, but I didn't have to, I didn't have that restraint, you know.
After I ran my own business at Freelance, as a writer, as an artist, I did little film work here, little TV work there.
I did some ghost writing, rewriting scripts for other people and things like that.
Some freelance public relations for about 10 years.
Move back to Louisiana and went to work for the first division of Black culture of any state in the country.
Our friend Ruth Wesley was director Edwin Edwards, the guy they called Edwin Edwards Louisiana, started that.
Edwin Edwards did more for Black people than most of the other people who followed him.
And for some strange reason, though they never mentioned this, Edwin Edwards always left the state in black.
Budget wise, the state was always in the black when Edwin Edwards was running it.
Now, like him or not, and I have friends who hate him, I try to look down the middle at it.
Why do you hate the guy who was supposedly Edwin Edwards who made money for everybody and who only took a dollar a year for his job?
Yeah, okay. So maybe you should have paid him a percentage of what he made.
You know, logically, for me, that might have made more sense because if he was going to see the state and he was making money, it made, you know.
But we made strides then, I think, because we were able to move agenda forward.
You know, we put out, I put out a national thing to all of the Black radio stations in the country or the radio stations with majority black audiences about.
And I'm not taking credit for this, but it became a thing.
Black 365, Black was the idea, you know, we're not just Black and February.
Okay. By that time, we are Black 365 days a year.
Let's go with this. The Mayor of Baton Rouge could tell you about that.
Keep hold of it because he was on radio at the time and I used to do a few things with him to let him know, you know, to put history into his show.
He was concerned about that. He was good. He went back to law school, became a legislator.
And now he's on his second or third term as Mayor of Baton Rouge.
The...
Can you come in on culture and politics being intertwined and not separate entities?
They are very much so because politics impact culture.
And a part of how that happens is if you are not concerned about the culture and you are in power, you can hurt cultures by overlooking them.
You know, I'm going to a meeting next week in Carrollton where one of the former City Council members is trying to create a project that stresses the diversity of the city, which is minority white technically.
But it's in terms of the majority of the City Council and those who govern it white.
Our conservative also.
So we have to deal with that, but it's how you have to deal with that.
Okay. Going back again, I moved back to Louisiana after I left the original Black culture, I went to work for this Louisiana State Museum.
It took about not quite a year off.
But when I went to the Louisiana State Museum, I was the second Black curator there.
I was the first Black Louisianaian and first male to have a curatorial job there.
We did get involved and my wife knows I'm not going to stay on this, but I fell in love with the Mardi Gras Indians.
And I did that in part because of the fact that I heard about my Indian heritage in the family and this and that from my father, from my uncle and from, you know, bits and pieces of this and that I wanted to find out about it.
So in 94 I did an exhibit on that.
One of the funny things about it was a white photographer decided that I was being prejudice because I, the show was about African-American photographers looking at the Black Indians and the Indians.
And I want to have a day asking to bring a note from his mother, certified that he was Black.
And, you know, he left us alone after that.
But we've never been great friends since then who won't be probably.
But, you know, I'm not going to miss him. I have enough friends.
The thing that I discovered along the way was a game.
Inter-office politics also, not just, you know, state, local government.
But it filters all the way down to the basic level where you have to sometimes remind people that look, stop and think before you react.
Because I looked at it like this. I said the first thing the average white person that I know and I'm using that generically is going to think about is how to do the white thing.
The people who want to do right will think that would stop.
You know, I'm not, I try not to be Black reactive.
You know, I'm not going to just react out of what I, I've accepted what I am culturally.
I know who I am. I define me, you know, I come myself an American African.
I'm an African descent. But everybody on this planet according to the folk that I know think about it, you know, and who are not bound by some religious myth or whatever.
Or understand where mankind started in that place we now call Africa.
So, we're all Africans in that sense. Maybe as Johnson clear the poet said, we should call this planet Africa.
And get on with it, you know, because the climate made us look different.
And how we played with history comes out of who became the powers who got to write the story, you know, that line again.
You know, when I found that, until the lion writes his own story, the tale of the hunt will always glorify the hunter.
I, a friend, Khalid Hafiz, that I worked with at Jazz Fest in New Orleans.
I used to represent the museum doing things on a Black heritage stage. Then it became the African heritage stage, you know, over a period of time.
We, you have to, we had to make gradual changes to get people to understand what the culture was about and how we were approaching it so that it could be informative for everyone.
And hopefully elevate the level of consciousness for all of the people we were dealing with.
How we were able to, you know, I was able to go into schools and talk to kids and tell them about what it was like being in jail because I've been in jail.
They listened to that and understood that I wasn't kidding them.
There's no BS here. There is, I wasn't a hero. I was a foot soldier.
I think of myself as when it comes to civil rights. I was another person who was there. I was able to make some differences.
But my differences were on the one to one level more so than on the one to a thousand.
But I've always felt like this. I've had a little success in teaching kids about art and about history. And when I teach art, I teach art and history and music.
So we talk about the blues, we talk about jazz, we talk about the history of African people in the world.
And the interactions between the groups of people. Why and how people think of different things?
This is what I think we need to know. I think we have to be self-defining.
I define Chuck Siler based on what I learned from history. But I've had a chance over the years to meet all kinds of folk.
I've had friends who did all sorts of things. You know, Lenny Bruce's mother brought me chicken soup when I had the flu.
Sally Marr was a thing. And I knew how to do other friends who were comics.
They knew me because I was a cartoonist and I was accepted as a comic because I did cartoons.
And sometimes wrote a line here or two. I've been an official cartoonist for two comedy clubs.
The comedy story at one point in the early 70s and the improv in the early 80s.
Because I lived in the neighborhood. I hung out there. The comics knew I was a writer. They knew I was a cartoonist.
We had sometimes very serious discussions about perceptions. How we perceived each other. What was funny? Why was it funny?
If you could tell a black joke, I could tell a good Polish joke. I could tell a joke about anybody if it were that way.
And I wasn't afraid to because if you thought you could bring it, if you can't take it, don't bring it.
It was the case. And you know, I've got some old friends that we can't laugh out loud about some of the things that we've laughed about over the years.
But they all understand that the bottom line is the humanity.
This is what we have to work to work. And this is how we have to deal with those people who are too stupid to understand.
You know, who one plus one has to be three. You're giving time now.
I was going to say, I think that might be perfect right there. I was going to ask you a final question if you could comment on the power of the pen and the power of humor.
I think this. People, you know, I have a good audience. You know, we were talking earlier that was still you.
I'm regular, I'm editorial page. Can I tune this for the Louisiana weekly? The black commentator uses my stuff.
I've got, oh God, 10 people, good friends, the Louisiana folk and that puts it out. Whatever I send it to them.
I've written about it and I still do right occasionally about it. You know, do a little review, things like that.
I've got friends, I guess, with every walk of life. A lot of them are in academia. Some of them are now retired from there.
A lot of them are professional journalists. You know, I hear from them when if I get slightly off-track, you know,
if I don't use enough female characters in the cartoons, I have some lady friends who will say, you don't use enough women.
I said, okay, you know, I'm, I'm, let me remind me if I, you know, because you do what's, what's instinctive, what's natural.
I find that if I can make a person laugh more often than not, they'll remember what I said.
If I hear, I notice that when sometimes I do things and I get responses from places that I didn't expect or from people that I didn't expect to hear from.
Okay, I had a instructor who died a few weeks ago. Name was Huel Perkins. When we did the Baton Rouge bus boycott piece, I was talking about Doug Rickley and some of the other guys who were there dugin.
Like I said, we were on different ends of the podium, but we caught everybody in the middle of the dead.
I told the story about how Dr. Perkins used to close his classes. I had a humanity class under him in an amphitheater style role, a choir role, and I will always set up at the back where I could watch everything going on.
Dr. Perkins used to like to close with Ross Dyer with Cyrano de Bergerac, who my later found out was the father of modern science fiction in real life.
Yeah. He would cite rock sounds, realization that Cyrano was the person who wrote those letters, of Christian.
And girls would get up and walk out of the class, leave their purses, leave their coats in the wintertime, and come back in embarrassed.
And I sit back and say, I got to be like that. You know, I said, I want to be like him. I want to be able to do that. I want to be able to make them listen.
You know, he was one of the teachers that I had who could convince a class like that. You know, the charismatic teacher.
So you try to take a little bit of each one of those, but I had him almost fall out of his seat because we used to play tennis together.
And I tell him he was the most literate trash talker tennis player that I met in my house. And he loved it. But when I wrote my last column from a student newspaper, he sent me a note telling me to keep on doing that.
And he says, you honor. He encouraged me. Go on with that. So, you know, here I am 50 some of our years later, trying to do the same thing. And when I look back at the people who contributed to who I am, I carry a little piece of all of them.
You know, when John Hope Franklin and Lonnie Bunch and the guy sent the letter saying, you know, they want you to do this. It was just about, I got that letter about a few days after Ethan was born.
Okay, I said, I got a grandson. I got to leave something so that one day when my son takes his son to that museum, if they want to call up the interview and see it, I want him to understand, you know, something about his heritage, his personal heritage.
You know, who raised your daddy? You know, so you can go out there and you can be your own man because that's what it's about.
You know, it's the same thing that you get when you, when I talk to kids at my workshops, you know, we sit down and we talk about music.
I tell them about who Alvin Batiste was, who Danny Barker was, who these musicians that came out of our whole town, the Marsalises, you know, who Henry Butler is.
I let them hear the music, let them hear brass band music, talk to them about the art of what the Mardi Gras Indians do, mobile art.
Okay, every time, you know, you come into a museum like this, one of the greatest collections of folk art that you're going to find is right here where we sit.
Okay, Henry Robinson has been collecting for years. The fact that we have to celebrate this, we have to understand why it's done.
What motivates the artist is not money because if it were just money, I'd like to be wealthy.
But I don't stop doing the art because of the fact that I'm not wealthy. Okay, I have something to say and I have an audience. I play with that.
You know, I try to reach the audience. My audience extends it. And sometimes I hear from places like I said that I never expected to hear from because a friend of mine sent it out to his business list.
And I have one guy in California who does that. He's got a big list. I wish mine were. But here's people who rescinded, you know, email. If I had email 30 years, if we had email in 1960,
the Civil Rights Movement would have been over by that day, 365. The way we were approaching it because we would have been hitting people.
You would have been able to open your computer without getting us. You know, the thing is that when I look back at that, I said,
boy, when I had meld in those guys at Southern playing ball, I said, if I had emailed that, you know, it was memio graph copy walk in, go to a press conference.
And if you had to do it with the pro teams, and I had that once with the Rams, I literally memorized my stats. So I wouldn't have to stand up there and constantly refer to it because of what was expected.
And here's this guy from this little black school. Okay. So those teachers who told me you had to be three times as good.
We're bringing my air saying, you know, you got to be sure how good you are. And it's something that I think was a part of that motivation. And it's a part of what is ongoing in terms of wouldn't motivate me to try to continuously make a statement.
You know, and to make a statement that is a human statement more so than just a stupid, you know, someone asked me once Mr. Hubbard gene Paul, I studied with gene Paul Hubbard and Frank Hayden.
Frank Hayden was a sculptor.
We had a lot of one on one conversations Harold Cureau, who taught me things that paid my rent for a long time. He taught commercial art and graphic design and that.
These guys always stressed the fact that we had to, you know, be able to get out and not be them. You know, it's don't say you're not a little gene Paul Hubbard.
You're not a little Frank Hayden. You're going to be we sending you out to be Chuck Siler.
And this is what you, you know, this is what I represent. You know, all of those people who, I named the guys who were to jail with me, the Willie Bradford, Willie Bradford jerked me away from a door that would have taken off my left hand because a deputy sheriff slapped on it.
There was a lady I forgot to mention and I got to do this to close it if before in 1962 when I was doing the broader registration project.
There was a lady who lived in an area that they called the park. I remember her name is Miss Williams. I could be wrong after all this time, but she reminded me when she went to register the vote. She got front twice.
Okay, over BS. But she was determined. She was 84 years old in 1962 that she was going to vote before she died.
She was going to be a registered voter. She was going to have the card. And the third time she went in, I went with her.
Now, I was young and stupid and not unlike a lot of folk. I was 19 years old. I had my gun stashed under my jacket in the back.
And if anybody had done anything, it could have been a real bad scene that day. And I would have been remembered for something else. Okay, but she was going to go in there.
When she walked through, it was like, lowly sea lion walking through those same guys about seven or eight months before when we got out of jail at January.
For whatever reason, they wanted to intimidate one old lady. And they failed horribly. Because she walked through. She reminded me of Mary McLeod Bethune, but doing I always think of her when I remember this lady dressed well, put on a nice suit.
And Charles were going. And someone drove us down. I forget who it was. But we walked in. And like I said, I was prepared to shoot somebody.
If they had decided to go that far, they didn't because when she walked in, she was in charge. They moved aside. She walked.
And she walked into the register. I was, I was sure you can't go in there. I said, no problem. I stood back against the wall. You know, and I got a corner. Okay, vantage point, advantage point as readers always look for. Okay.
And I was waiting. And I was standing there like this. And I was pressing that little burr at her. Because I wanted to say when she came out, she had to smile on her face. Okay.
That made all of it worth it. It was, you know, as good as it could get at that moment because she got what she wanted. And she got the vote before she died.
And, you know, you think about being 84 in 1962. Her parents had been slaves. Okay, to her, it was important. You know, I'm, I'm a person who gets upset when somebody tells me they can't go. They're not going to vote.
I don't care if you, you know, vote for the person who's going to do you the least harm if nothing else.
But try to understand what and why you're doing it. You know, understand. I'm, I learned from my wife every day. My wife being a government teacher.
You know, I want of her better students. And what happens? I passed the test when I can make her laugh.
Because to a large degree, that's what it's about. If I can put an idea that she passes on to me out and get a reaction from my public, one of the things that artists always want. And I think it's, it happens in anything else.
You don't want on week. You want a positive reaction or negatively, you want a reaction. I don't care what the reaction is because I got a good friend who's a Republican who is die hard.
Okay, die hard, black Republican. He's not quite as far right as out of west of those people. And I managed to bring him back a bit. But we have had some great arguments. But we love each other like brothers.
And we will fight intellectually like brothers. And my point is we have less, I have less. I learned from him because I learned what that side is thinking.
My buddy who's a libertarian. I learned what the libertarians are thinking. I have two good friends who are imams. Okay. They aren't radicals. You know, they aren't going to go out and blow anybody up. They are parents.
But we can talk because my Baptist minister buddies, I haven't been, you know, I go to church for filenals. Okay. I have my own belief. It took years. And it took black preachers who didn't want to become a part of it to make me go to look.
You know, the minister at the church that I used to attend wouldn't let me do workshops for the registration in his church because he was afraid. Okay. I was not being afraid. And I couldn't respect him because of the fact that how are you going to tell me you believe in something that you scared to stand up for it.
You know, I said, what would Jesus Christ do to you? You know, what would you have to say about you if you didn't, you know, what would the prophet Muhammad have to say if you didn't stand up? You know, I liked the Quakers because the American friends service committee helped us out a lot during the civil rights movement. Yeah, we had, they gave us places to meet. We did what we could, you know.
So that's, you know, I don't know if there's much more to say. I would be, I would be the same. Stop.
I didn't want to stop. I don't want to stop. But we got to get on our planet. Of course, but so let me just say, again, thank you so much.
Oh, hey, I appreciate this has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.